make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
you got a friend in me yeah you got a
friend in me
i'm wendy newman hello
everyone and welcome back to comics
explained
[Laughter]
uh we are covering venom yes we are the
the follow-up
to what it is that directly happened to
eddie brock right because in the last
video that we did i left you guys on
like this insane cliffhanger right and
like venom died
and all that eddie brock is dead with
that being said guys and just bounced
and you guys were like
no it was kind of amazing
but uh in this video we find out what
actually happened to eddie brock
right so the cool thing about this is we
would largely assume
that eddie brock had died but the the
way that donnie cage plays this is
amazing and this is why donnie case
this is why i'm really really liking
donnie kate's when he first took over
venom and even when he wrote thanos and
things like that it was kind of hard to
get a gauge
of what kind of writer donnie cates was
you knew he was a great writer but you
didn't know the nuances behind his
writing style
and what we're kind of learning here is
donnie cates is almost kind of like this
perfect blend
between like jonathan hickman and scott
snyder and jeff johns where he plants
these little seeds these little tidbits
of things that might become important
later on and they actually do
right so in this instance eddie brock
when his body basically dies right when
he's
effectively killed that he just kind of
comes falling down into this place
called the abyss right now this happens
immediately
as soon as he hits the vehicle right so
this is before he dies at the end of the
last video
that he was technically quote unquote
dead before that happened that his body
just kind of fallen
you know into this this sort of
underbelly right this sort of abyss and
he kind of talks about these things
right like you know he's fallen before
and there's only darkness and things
like that that he can see his physical
form you know that it's kind of in the
world above him but it's almost like on
a spiritual level he's kind of losing
himself
and donnie kate's almost kind of plays
it fast and loose with the idea of like
what happens when a person dies
because marvel doesn't really give us
any sort of consistent explanation on
that right like if you go and you read
the old chris claremont x-men stories
for example you get a depiction of what
the realm of mistress death actually
looks like
right where it's basically just all
these really really tall pillars and
each one represents somebody's afterlife
but then you have like the realm of
mephisto where you have
you know one of the versions of health
that's basically kept by the various
hell lords and then you have like the
realm of hella right which is called
hell in and of itself
you know and that's where people who are
dead go and you have all these different
indications and depictions of of like
where the soul goes when a person dies
but for eddie here
you know in the midst of this place that
he's in it's not really
really recognizable to him but then he
kind of hears this disembodied voice and
it's just like
brock right it's just you know and it
just literally jars him right like that
and he's just like
wake up and it's really cool you know he
addresses him as like a soldier he's
like wake up soldier you know and he's
like knows minions like they have you
man
like and this is what was really given
to us where we end up finding out that
where he's at right now is he's part of
the hive
right he's he's part of the collective
hive of knoll the symbiote god that yes
his
physical body's dead but his essence has
kind of moved on and there's a reason
why this happens and it's really really
cool
but you know one of the things that this
disembodied voice basically tells them
is if you're going to move right
like what you need to do you need to
make yourself stop right like if you're
going to break out of this hive or at
least
try to you know maintain your sanity in
this hype and keep from being consumed
by
like all the symbiotes you know
basically null himself then you have to
maintain your own self
and the only way to do that is to stop
yourself from falling and the only way
to stop yourself from falling is to
brace for impact
and land and that's exactly what he does
he does the superhero landing
right he does the superhero landing and
then suddenly he's met by a guy he
doesn't recognize
now if you're if you're familiar with
donnie case's venom run you do know who
this guy is right and it took me a
minute to remember i was like who in the
heck is this and i was like that's right
and it turns out to be rex strickland
right now rex strickland for those of
you guys who are a little fuzzy here on
his character
rex strickland was one of the guys who
was kind of bonded to a venom symbiote
during the days of the vietnam war
i think it was a vietnam war but he was
basically one of the first people in the
history of the world to be bonded with a
venom semi he only had it for a few
years
and then ultimately rex strickland ended
up dying as far as i'm aware and instead
his symbiote basically
replicated it right it took his place
the rest of rex strickland's team ended
up dying but
all that was kind of lead up to the
notion or the introduction of the idea
of the grindel and like null and all
that kind of stuff uh we've got videos
on it if you guys want to go check it
all out kind of get yourself fully
refreshed on the the nature of the
character but what he basically says
here where eddie brock kind of asked the
question like why am i here right
because he sees like a handful of people
running and he jumps in to try to save
them but they're like ghosts right he
literally just passes right through them
he can't really touch them he can't
interact with him so it's really more
him that's the ghost and there's even
like a giant dragon that comes like
flying down
and seems to know that eddie's there
right and eddie like goes to attack it i
don't know what he was going to do
by punching a dragon but the dragon just
kind of flies right it just kind of
blows right through him and almost kind
of it gives him the feeling that like
he's being ripped apart
and so what he ends up doing at least
what he's told by uh by rex here
is that the reason why he's in this
place is because of the codex
because if you guys remember that one of
the things that donnie kate's
established is that every time a
symbiote
bonds itself to a host that when the
symbiote leaves that host
it leaves behind a kind of codex inside
that host and so what this
is to make this a lot easier to
understand this is just one small
aspect of eddie brock's consciousness
essentially right if you could break his
consciousness down to like an almost
bio-technological organism
it would be the codex and that's where
it is now right his consciousness has
been absorbed into null by virtue of the
codex because he was a symbiote at one
point in time and it's one of these
things where it almost seems to point to
this idea that whenever a person who is
a host for a symbiote dies that they
almost kind of join this black abyss
right it's almost like the the afterlife
like where
speedsters join the speed force this is
where symbiote hosts go now it's not
absolute
it's not concrete because we see people
here who have basically been absorbed by
null when they were consumed by
symbiotes but it almost kind of lends
credence to it right it's not like
somebody out there was shot in the head
and some mugging gone wrong and then now
they're part of null right like every
single
person that you see here every single
body that you see here is a person who
was contacted with a symbiote and then
absorbed into null well the question
becomes if that's the case
if rex strickland is here because of of
his shred of consciousness
surviving through the codex and being
absorbed by null and if eddie brock is
here because his
portion of his consciousness was was
absorbed through the codex and now is
part of null then why isn't anybody else
moving around and talking
right why are they the only ones who are
really aware of what's going on and
everybody else just looks like
characters out of the matrix
the reason why is because of the fact
that they had been bonded with symbiotes
for so long their connection is stronger
than everybody else's
one thing to keep in mind here everybody
here that you see strung up right ben
grimm
captain america vision all these
different characters that they were
bonded with symbiotes for moments right
like it was literally you know seconds
or if they weren't bottled with the
symbiote over the course of their
publication history it was only for like
a single event right or for a few
moments in time
whereas rex strickland had his symbiote
for years and eddie brock had his
symbiote for years still right for for
even longer than that and so it's kind
of a crazy thing where you know where
eddie doesn't fully grasp
the reality of what's going on that this
kind of realm that they're in
is almost a mirror they're almost really
in the real world but the the reality is
it's almost like an illusion right it's
almost like a mirror of the real world
they can't really react with anything
they can't really touch anything they
can just kind of exist in that place and
that's it they just sort of exist and
they stay there
and there really doesn't seem to be any
true escape and it's one of the things
that eddie kind of asks well then like
why can't i go back to the real world
right i mean if my consciousness is
alive here then why can't i simply just
leave this place and go back
he's like you not know like you do are
you he's like dude you don't know and
it's like eddie brock you're dead man
like you're literally laying dead on a
hospital bed and like your kid's crying
over you like and it's one of the things
where eddie freaks right eddie
absolutely freaks out when he when he
hears that and this is one of the cool
things right this is one of the best
things about this
because donnie kate's i'm going to say
this i don't care
what anybody out there says donnie
kate's handling a venom
is probably the single best handling of
the venom character
in the history of marvel comics right
and i don't really even believe there's
anybody who can argue that point
adequately right they might be able to
make a couple good points here and there
but nobody could actually maintain
that point for the long haul and say
actually agent venom's run was much
better now this this run is far more
complex it's a lot more nuanced
agent venom's great but it's no donnie
kate's venom run right it's just not on
this same level but it's kind of crazy
here because what you end up getting is
is eddie brock just kind of freaking out
and saying like over the course of my
whole life i've had to give things up
i've lost things i've had things taken
from me like i'm literally a man
of sacrifice and loss and i'm not gonna
let them take this right like i'm not
gonna let them take
my death like if i'm gonna die it's
gonna be on my terms and so his whole
his whole idea here is okay
if we can walk around inside this void
right this abyss this living abyss where
null reigns supreme
then if i'm here that means my
symbiote's here so it's like i'm gonna
find my symbiote and working together
we can bust out of this place right we
can literally break away from the hive
mind and just kind of show up now the
reality and this is one of the big
differences here
until eddie brock's consciousness merges
with his physical body
it would basically be his consciousness
hitching a ride alongside the symbiote
the simi it would appear
and it would look like eddie brock but
it wouldn't really be his physical form
assuming that even happens
and the reason why i say assuming is
because rex says okay like i believe you
on this man and i believe that you can
do it right i mean you're a hard-hitting
guy i kind of misjudged you a little bit
but here's the problem that you have
finding your symbiote is not going to be
the problem getting to it and freeing it
that's the problem because we find out
that when null took the symbiote of
eddie when he took
took the the actual venom simeon he
didn't just disperse it among the you
know everything else in the abyss
instead he keeps it close he holds on to
it right so eddie's literally gonna have
to find a way
to get to knoll and then steal his
symbiote back and that's when he's kind
of like okay
well i mean how am i supposed to get up
there by by myself and the responsive of
rex is no no you don't have to do it by
yourself man right you don't have to do
it by yourself i'm gonna go with you but
here's the more important thing
yes i recruited you for this mission and
then you know to help me go back
and take these symbiotes like yes i
recruited you as a kind of agent you
know that's what i wanted you to be but
the reality is that you were not an
agent eddie brock you were never really
an agent you know you were a guy
who came across a symbiote one day and
did some things and and you've been
bonded with it for a long time but you
were not the kind of man i was looking
for
fortunately inside this place i
did find the man that i was looking for
only for us to find out
that that agent venom flash thompson has
returned with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you